ب 40,000 طالب وعشره ملايين دولار ارباح
نواب كويتيين بيعلنوا الحرب على اضخم
عمليه غش منظم سمعنا فيها قلوب الارض وقف
دورانه وفي طريقه للانعكاس رواد المنصات
بيلطم وبيسالوا العالم هينتهي وصناع باب
الحاره يردون على ياسر العظمه بعد فتحها
النار على المسلسل اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
نبدا من الكويت وخبر عن عمليات غش منظمه
قالبه الدنيا وممكن حتى نسميها بصراحه
اضخم عمليه غش يمكن في التاريخ ما ادري بس
انه اكيد من الاضخم احنا بنتكلم عن غش صار
في الامتحانات الثانويه العامه متورط فيها
او في هذه العمليه 40,000 طالب والعصابات
المسؤوله عن الغش جمعت من وراءها ثلاثه
ملايين دينار كويتي يعني عشره مليون دولار
الكلام عن عمليات الغش هذه ترى من فتره
وشوفنا ايش معنى اخبار عنها كثير لكن
الجديد اليوم هو انه في مجلس الامن او في
مجلس همم الامه اخذوا وقفه من الموضوع
وطالب 10 منهم بعقد جلسه خاصه في الاول من
فبراير لمناقشه ظاهره الغش في المدارس
وتسريب اسئله الامتحانات اللي صارت خلال
امتحانات الثانويه العامه وراح يتم خلال
الجلسه مناقشه الحلول اللازمه لمحاربه هذه
الظاهره وتقديم بياناتها عن الا
والاحصائيات حول وراح يتكلموا كمان عن
اتهامات للمدارس خاصه بالطورط في الغش
لرفع النتائج المدرسه طيب اللي صار خلال
الامتحانات الثانويه العامه زي ما قلنا
يعني تابع كل الكويتيين اخباره وشفنا كلام
عن تسريب الاسئله الامتحانات عبر جروبات
على الواتساب باسماء وهميه للطلاب وبارقام
مقيمين بنغاليين وعبره سماعات خاصه
بيلبسها الطلاب خلال الامتحان حتى وقت
الامتحانات في طلاب نقلوا للمستشفيات
وطلعوا من اذنهم سماعات دقيقه بيغشوا من
خلالها وفي اخبار كمان
بنفسهم ما شاء الله بيساعدوا اولادهم على
الغش وسائل الاعلام كويتيه قالت نقلا عن
مصدر من النيابه العامه انه في 20 متهم او
في 20 متهم في هذه القضيه بيتملاحقهتهم
ورح يتم اتخاذ الاجراءات القانونيه بحقهم
اما وزاره التربيه فكانت اصدرت بيان في 26
الشهر قالت فيه انه ما راح تتوانا في
تطبيق كل القوانين اللي بتدعم العمليه
التعليميه ورحت حارب هذه الظاهره السلبيه
اللي بتصير خلال فتره الامتحانات مع
الجهات المعنيه وكمان كانت الوزاره اصدرت
بيان امس قالت في ان مستمره بمحاربه ظاهره
الغش وان هي تعاونت مع وزاره الداخليه
وعملت خطه عمل قبل فتره امتحانات الفصل
الدراسي الاول للتخلص من ظاهره الغش والحد
منها واكد انها ريحه الحاسب كل متورط مهما
كان منصبه الوظيفي وراحت تتخذ الاجراءات
القانونيه بحق الطلاب اللي هتثبت عليهم
تهمه الغش في الامتحانات
[موسيقى]
مجله نيتشر العلميه مجله دوريه لها وزنها
يعني وثقلها ومن كم يوم نزلت فيها نتائج
دراسه عامله صدى كبير الدراسه عنوانها
عباره عن سؤال وبيقول هل توقف لب الارض
الداخلي عن دورانو وفي التفاصيل كانوا
بيقولوا العلماء الي شغالين على الدراسه
في جامعه بكين انه رصد انه اللب الداخلي
لكوكب الارض واللي معروف ان هو بيدور توقف
عن الدوران العقد الماضي وبس كده لا هو
الان في مرحله تعادل انعكاس الدوران
وبتوقع انه يرجع يبدا بالدوران لكن
بالاتجاه المعاكس وقال العلماء في الدراسه
انا الموضوع راح يكون له اثار على كوكب
الارض ولكن ما بتوصل لدرجه الخطوره الشديد
الدراسه بتتوقع انه الدوران العكسي هيبدا
في 20 40 والعلماء من زمان كانوا توصلوا
لانه بالارض بيدور بسرعه اكبر من قشرتها
الخبر هذا طبعا انتشر من هنا
والدنيا كلها طبعا مملت اسئله واستفسارات
وكلام عن انه ايش كثير قوي تغيير اللي
هيحجزوا هذا الامر على الكوكب والبشري
ونسرحت ابعد من كده كمان وبدات تتكلم من
هذه النتائج معناها انه لا نهايه العالم
اقتربت والناس بتقول انه لا انعكاس
الدوران يعني الشمس هتشرق من الغرب وهذه
عاد من علامات يوم القيامه عشان نفهم
الموضوع لازم نتكلم معه نقطه فخلونا نسال
ضيفنا اللي بينضم الينا من القاهره استاذ
الجيولوجيا دكتور عباس شرقي اهلا فيك معنا
الدكتور عباس همم هل نقدر نقول انه نحن
مقبلين على يعني كارثه ونهايه العالم
والكلام هذا كله
لا اولا تحياتي لحضرتك ولكل الساده
للمشاهدين
الحقيقه يعني هذا البحث جاء ببعض
المعلومات عن ااا مركز الكره الارضيه اللي
بنقول عليه اللب الكره الارضيه ده اللوجو
الكره الارضيه عباره عن كره حديديه مكونه
من حديد ونيكل وبالتالي هي وزنها يعني
كبير بالنسبه لباقي صخور القشره الارضيه
هذه الكره بتدور مع الارض ونفس الاتجاه
وحاول نفس محور الكره الارضيه هذه الكتله
الحديديه
بتنمو مع الوقت بتزيد وهي المسؤوله عن
الجاذبيه في الكره الارضيه ايوه هي
المسؤوله عن المجال المغناطيسي اللي موجود
في الكره الارضيه واللي بيحمي ال- الكره
الارضيه وبما انه بيزيد في الحجم لان مع
مرور الوقت بيحصل تبريد للكره الارضيه
وبتتكون بلورات حديديه
بتنجذب لهذه الكتله لان هذه الكتله محاطه
همم منطقه كلها صهير يعني سوائل فهي كتله
حديديه صلبه والحقيقه هنا صلبه في وسط
حراره اكثر من 7,000 درجه مئويه وهنا يجيء
السؤال كيف لحراره 7,000 درجه مئويه ويبقى
في كتله صلبه ايا كان حتى لو حديد لان
الحديد ينصهر عند قويه فهنا الحديث السؤال
ده ولا ده انا باقول انا باسال واجاوب
اوكي تمام
احنا فهمنا هذا اللبوه العكس انت الان
شرحت انه هو مسؤول عن الجاذبيه وامور مهمه
كثير يعني طيب الان لما ينعكس الموضوع
اشرح يصير
ما هو انا بما انه مسؤول عن الجاذبيه وهو
كتله حديديه
والسائل او الصهير المحيط بيه هذا الصهير
في حركه دائمه وبالتالي بيتولد تيار
كهربائي وبتلد مجال مغناطيسي هنا في
النقطه انا هاجي لحضرتك ما الفائده هذا
هذا الدوران بيجعل الكتله الحديديه
مغناطيس قوي جدا بيجذب الحديد اللي بيتكون
اليه وبالتالي بينمو ويكون المغناطيس
الكره الارضيه هنا ال- ال- ال- احنا درسنا
الكلام ده عرفناه ازاي ما فيش طريقه لان
ده على عمق 5,000 كيلو متر ما نقدرش نجيبه
وبعدين في وسط 7000 درجه مئويه فازاي
المعلومات جاءت جبناها عن طريق الزلازل
اللي بتحصل على سطح الارض بين القصه في
الوجه الاخر من الكره الارضيه وبالتالي
الصخور فاحنا في همم الصخور اللي على
الحواف اللي هي لا يمر بها الموجات
بنجد ان السرعات ثابته لكن لما الموجات
تمر بمركز الارض لان ان السرعه مختلفه هذا
معناها ان في شيء في في مركز الكره
الارضيه هذا معناه ان في دوران البحث بقى
هنا بقى الجديد في البحث انه بيقول ان ان
احنا شوفنا ان السرعه ان السرعه ثابته
وبالتالي ده معناه ان هل الكتله توقفت عن
الدوران لكن في همم الاحتمال الاكبر وهو
ان هذه الكتله بتدور مع الارض بنفس سرعه
دوران الارض هذا معناه انها تعتبر ثابته
بالنسبه للارض هذا شيء احنا بنلمسه
بالدوران القمر حوالين الارض طالما بنفس
الشركات الارض
لا تضيعني انا انسانه يعني معلومات على
جده
ده انا معلومات جدا
هيلف او هيتغير انتم اكتشفته ايش بيعمل
واكتشفته ايش اللي بيغير حركاته وان هو
بيدور وبنعكس الان اللي انعكاس ده خطر
لم يثبت انه هينعكس
الثابت دلوقتي في البحث اللي بيقول ان
السرعه خلال ال 10 سنوات الاخيره ما
تغيرتش لم تتغير معناه وكان هذه الكتله
الكره الحديديه كانها ثابته لكن هي لا هي
في الحقيقه هي متحركه بنفس سرعه الكره
الارضيه فبالنسبه للاشعه اللي بتمر او
الموجات الزلزاليه بتمر بنفس المكان فاذا
ده بيؤكد ما كنا نعلمه قبل كده فقالوا في
دوره دوره في 35 سنه هذه الكره
بتدور بسرعه اكبر قليله من سرعه الارض ثم
تقل تدريجيا الى ان تتساوى في فتره مع
شجره الارض ثم بعد كده تقل عن سرعه الارض
هذه الدوره مدتها 70 سنه احنا دلوقت في
منتصف هذه الدوره معنى ذلك ان هذه الكتله
بتدور حاليا بنفس سرعه الارض وهذا يؤكد
طالما انه بنفس السرعه يبقى
همم
الزمن معناها ان ما فيش تغير في السرعات
حاليا اللي مقاسه البوبالتالي يعني اللي
بيخلي البعض انها خلاص توقفت لا هي لم
تتوقف ولن تدور في الاتجاه المعاكس لان ده
هيبقى مخالف للكره الارضيه هذه الكتله هي
المسؤوله عن الجاذبيه مسؤوله عن اشياء
كثيره على سطح الارض منها بعض الموجات
البحريه مسؤوله عن بعد ممكن همم ده يفسر
والحقيقه ده عامل من ضمن العوامل الكثيره
اللي ممكن نقول انها ممكن تؤثر في
التغيرات المناخيه ولذلك احنا بنشوف في
بعض الموجات في سنوات تكون حاره في سنوات
تكون درجه الحراره فيها منخفضه في سنوات
يكون فيها جفاف شديد في سنوات اخرى
بيفسر ان ربما
ان ان اللب ده يكون له تاثير على ما يحدث
على سطح الارض لكن ما يحدث الان ليس بجديد
على الكره الارضيه ولكن الجديد بالنسبه
لنا احنا معلوماتنا احنا احنا
بنزيد من معلوماتنا لانها لب الكوره
الارضيه على عمق 5000 كيلو وما فيش وسيله
ما فيش رحله تنزل تحت الارض ولا هذه
الصخور انها تطلع على سطح الارض البراكين
بتطلع من ال 100 كيلو الاولى واحنا عندنا
نصف الكره الارضيه اكثر من 6,000 و300
كيلو متر فبالتالي هذا الجزء واحنا كمان
عرفنا ل- اا المكون بتاع ان هو حديد ونيكل
منين لان قلنا الجاذبيه في هذا الجزء
بتبقى اكبر طيب والتكوين التركيب
الكيميائي والصخري عرفناه من النيازك اللي
بتنزل على سطح الارض لانها بتكون اقرب ما
يكون يعني احنا حتى عرفنا انه حديث يعني
اهميه همم انه الدور اللي بيصير واللي
بيصير هذه الحركه والسرعه والكلام هذا كله
طب الان الدراسه هذه لمن طلعت ليش صارت
حاله الفزع هذه والناس قالوا انه العالم
هينتهي والناس قالوا انه الشمس راح تطلع
من
غرب ما انه الارض حينعكس ليش صار هذا
الكلام
هذا كلام في مبالغه شديده ولا يعني حتى
البحث نفسه لم يحذر من مخاطر ولكن كل ما
بنوصل لمعلومه بيظهر لنا عشرات الاسئله
الاخرى هنا الكتله الحديديه ما هو شكل
الكتله الحديديه هل هي مكوره هل هي
بيضاويه هل همم نفس لان الكره الارضيه
نفسها بيضاويه فبالتالي ايه شكل هذا الجزء
وكيفيه الدوران اسئله كثيره ويمكن البحث
خرج في النهايه في التوصيات الاخيره ان
المطلوب مزيد من الابحاث لمعرفه معلومات
اكثر عن هذا الجزء الهام بالنسبه للكره
الارضيه يعني تمنياتي لكم بالتوفيق في هذه
همم ايوه والله دي من البدايه بس انا
دكتور والله اه دي النقطه المهمه فعلا اه
بالضبط يا دكتور طيب المهم استمروا في
الابحاث وان شاء الله ما يصير اي خطر لا
علينا ولا على الكره الارضيه ويمشي حالنا
انا حتى
يعني من الفزع اللي عندي بس مش عارفه اجلس
على الكرسي على العموم اشكرك على وجودك
معانا كان معنا من القاهره استاذ
الجيولوجيا دكتور عباس شرافي شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
من اول ما بدا الفنان ياسر العظمه ينشر
محتوى برنامج الجديد على قناه على
اليوتيوب واللي اسمه مع ياسر العظمه
الانتقادات ما بتتوقف وكل حلقه بتعمل
بلبله من كم يوم نزلت حلقه من البرنامج
مسلسل باب الحاره الشهير اللي يمكن ما في
حد تابع الاقل سمع فيه وفي ناس بتنتظره
خلال الموسم من الرمضاني له 12 سنه بيعرض
خلال رمضان وتم الاعلان كمان عن الجزء 13
هذا الموسم ياسر العظمه تكلم في الفيديو
عن مسلسل باب الحاره والقائمين عليه بهذا
الكلام
معظم مسلسلاتنا السوريه عم تكون مسلسلات
تنبه بان من يقف خلفها اما ان يكون جاهلا
او اميا او تاجرا او غبيا او مغرضا او
كلها المعاني سواء باب الحاره يلي عم
يحاولوا جهدهم يعملوا منه امام المسلسلات
السوريه بما يحمله من تاريخ مزور وافتراء
سافر على حقبه مهمه من تاريخ سوريا
المسلسل الغير واقعي بس ما حدا لحدا وكل
ما ازداد اللوم ازدادت التناحه والجاره
وراح يستمر باب الحاره باجزاؤه ليوم
القيامه شاء من شاء وابا من ابا
يلي عم يكتب المسلسل
[موسيقى]
شو هالتجني الممزوج والافتراء التاريخ باب
الحاره قصه متخيله فانتازيا وهميه ملا
اساس بتسيء للتاريخ السوري وبتشوف الحقائق
وبتعتم على اسماء كبيره
الكلام هذا اللي تكلم فيه ياسر العظمه عن
العمل ما مر مرور الكرام وعمل رده فعل عند
القائمين عليه رد الاول جاء من منتج العمل
محمد قبل نضج اللي قال انه اي احد يجيب
سيرته او سيره باب الحاره هو شخص غيران
لانه
مشارك في المسلسل وشخص بيبحث عن الترند
لكنه كمان رجعوا قالوا انه بيحب ياسر
العظمه بيحترموا مو زعلان من هجوم على
المسلسل الشخص
الجمهور ومن بعدهم طلع مؤلف العمل مروان
قوي ورد على ياسر العظمه عبر برنامج
بالعربي والمؤلف ردوا كان اقصى وطالب
العظمه بالاعتذار
ولكن يعني
الكثير من الموروس للشعب الشامي هو هلا عم
يساوي السوري
وتامل الدين الاعتذاره قدم اعتذارك لمحبين
مشاهده الاعمال البيئيه الشاميه والاعمال
السوريه والاعمال السوريه بدي اقول لك انت
اسات لكل الكتاب السيناريو وانزلت من
مثواهم الفكري والنفس
هذا ما انا انا ما فاهم فيك
انا لما دخل الجامعه
السودانيه واقفل الطلاب يعني امام هذا
الحلم بنتكلم تحديدا عن الجامعه الوطنيه
السودان الاعلانات الحرب على حفلات التخرج
الخاصه مو بس الحفلات كمان الزفات ومواكب
الخريجين والاحتفالات في القاعات والغناء
والرقص كله كله هذه الاشياء يعني باختصار
كل مظاهر الاحتفال التخرج واصدره الجامعه
قرار بمنع اقامته ومشاركه الطلاب باي
فعاليات واحتفاليات
بالخرج خارج الحرم الجامعي يسمى الموضوع
بدعم محليليه
كمان الزمن الطلاب هيوقعوا على التعهد
اللي شايفينها امامكم واللي بيقولوا فيه
اعلم انه حفلات التخرج اللي بتنظمها
الشركات بتدعم محليه لا توجد في اي مؤسسه
التعليم عالي في العالم وتعهد امام ولي
امري
خلال او بعد التخرج فوافق على ايقاع اي
عقوبه تقررها رئاسه الجامعه او المجلس
العلمي علي بما يحفظ سمعه خريجيها وسمعه
مجتمع المعرفه في كل مكان
يعني كلام مره كبير الصراحه يعني لو
الطلاب احتفلوا برج الجامعه مع نفسهم او
كل واحد عمل حفله يعني وين المشكله يعني
ايش علاقه سمعه الخريجين ههه ولا سمعت مش
تبع المعدل اللي صار في الخطر
عجيب بصراحه القرار القرار قسم الشارع في
السودان في ناس من رايي انا مو فاهمه سبب
الحرب على الاحتفالات هذه وفي ناس مع
القرار ومرحب جدا وطالبه حتى بتعميمه وعلى
كل الجامعات يلا بلا فرح بلا احتفال
مشاهدين احنا وصلنا لختام حلقه اليوم انا
عدو القاكم غدا ان شاء الله في حلقه جديده
من تفاعلكم في امان الله
[موسيقى]